has anyone pitched uk cannon on pitch
perfect the musical
yes yes they have have you said yes
um i would do it in you know a hot
second
uh but um i think it's like
you know we when i think we were talking
about it like pitch three had just come
out
and they like want to wait till the
right time
but and right now doesn't feel like the
right time you know what i mean
i know what you mean i get it i get it i
get it kate cannon joins the show writer
director has the upcoming
cinderella on amazon prime but i bring
up pitch perfect kay
one because you know i love that movie
two because here in the rich eisen
studios that has all this memorabilia
all these photographs and sports
tchotchkes there is a pitch perfect 2
poster hanging up in the corner
and it's because you got the green bay
packers to perform
acapella and that's because you're a die
hard bears fan am i right
that's right trolling the packers in
your own movie that tells you everything
we need to know
about your fandom what was that like to
direct those guys and
to write a scene for those guys in pitch
perfect too
well to write they would they were they
were they're such fans they knew all the
choreography to the finale of
um pitch perfect and they i guess they
would do
the choreography um like on the road
like together and they would watch some
they would watch the movie on the road
um but i i loved they were open to doing
anything so writing for them was was
really fun and then also i would stop
myself and be like oh my gosh i cannot
believe i'm writing for them like
that they're that they were open to
doing whatever and all the different
jokes that i
did them and then i saw them the first
time i met them was at the premiere
actually and they
when we were like uh before going in and
i
ran up to them and and i thanked them
for doing the movie and then i was like
i'm a bears fan um
and they uh they were like get out of
here get out of here lady
how deep is that bear's love go i know
chicago sports are a thing we've talked
about a lot over the years but what are
some of your memories over the years
connected to the bears and how deep does
that fandom go
um well you know i have to admit like
recently i've i've um relaxed a little
bit just because like
well sold the bears so you're in good
company
uh but but for me like the 85-86
championship team is like
i think i was like 10 years old and
i'm one of seven kids and uh
you know with my mom and dad and
everything
we would you know that like sitting
around and watching on a sunday watching
the bears play
and that team in particular it was so it
was just magic
you know and so i i like you know my dad
passed away eight years ago and i have
his
bear's jacket um
and that you know in my in my closet and
you know it still smells like him and
it's just
just that whole like i remember like
buying a t-shirt
of the um you know 85 86 bears
uh like i'm from small town they were
selling t-shirts like on the corner of
like
main street which is like one of two
streets in the small town i grew up in
um and so just like and the fact that
they did the super bowl shuffle like it
was just like a really
magical time and when i um got married
you know uh my vows were all about like
walter payton and refrigerator perry
being uh you know a magical uh couple
um and like you know i i think i said
something like you know when i can't see
across the finish line i'll become
refrigerator perry and i'll throw you
across you know
like like when jerry perry threw walter
payton across the finish line against
the dolphins
uh um that's what every groom wants to
hear from his bride that they're going
to turn into refrigerator perry that's
sounds very romantic okay um
you know when i can't find my way he'll
become my refrigerator perry like goes
the whole thing
kate cannon joins the show right now
cinderella coming soon on amazon prime
what i love about pitch perfect and
hearing you talk about it you wrote that
film
as a sports movie what does a sports
movie mean to you and how does pitch
perfect fit into that
yeah i mean i i you know it was it's a
it's a it was a competition so it was
like a an
all-female group so growing up an
athlete on a lot of like basketball
teams and volleyball teams and
and and i ran track and played softball
like
i just knew that dynamic so to me it was
just like
i i felt it was the ultimate underdog
sports movie
because women an all female team had
never won
the itas which are the international you
know championships of acapella
and so that and then they had the rival
and they had like you know
who they had to beat in this case it was
like the all-male team
um and my favorite movies of like uh
of all time are like a rocky is like my
favorite movie all time and
hoosiers feel you guys mention field of
dreams like like
there's there's just um i just really
connect to those movies and so
i that's just how i approached it i
would imagine you're also connecting to
these olympics knowing you something
tells me you're a big olympic person
what events have you enjoyed and what
stories have inspired you
yeah i really um uh
you know it's it's interesting because
i'm of the time
zones you know you know the changes and
everything like that like i find myself
just like up all night
um watching uh simone biles obviously
that was
i i really was interested in watching
her win the bronze
um but when it comes to like track and
field like the um
you know that that 400 meter hurdler and
i'm
forgetting his name now um i believe he
was from denmark yeah
uh or he's from norway you're up at
three in the morning watching her
you know hurdles it all kind of blends
together after a while
i mean also the beach volleyball um that
was
pretty fun to watch watch the uh women
um
win the gold that was super fun um
and uh you know but it also like you
know i was a sprinter in in college and
just
watching the sprinters and of course
like
at the olympic level like an 800 meter
run is
is the sprint you know uh
so i'm just like so in awe of their
abilities
kate cannon joins the show writer
director has the upcoming cinderella for
amazon and something that's kind of like
your super power k
as a filmmaker uh as a director as a
writer is working with
undiscovered talent in sports we
celebrate young talent finding their sea
legs josh allen today getting a huge
extension
kind of unheralded coming out of college
and then you have guys like john moran
exploding on the scene or
sabrina out in brooklyn and so just
young talent
what is it that you enjoy so much about
working with people who haven't really
proven themselves on screen yet
i i love it man like i feel like um
i wouldn't necessarily cast them or take
them on if i didn't feel like it was
inside them already
you know and i think like if you compare
that to an athlete that just has like
raw
natural talent and ability and to be
able to like shape and mold that
um is really exciting to me so i you
like anybody i cast i do feel like i
have to see
something in them and um and then
and really it comes down to uh
this this notion of of hard work like i
think a big part of what i see in them
is if i feel like
they're going to work hard and try to
get it right and
and when i when i find somebody who's
coachable
that's just like that's just fun because
you're just taking
what their you know natural abilities
are and you're
helping them hone it and and they're and
they're thirsty to get that like
they want that kind of um you know uh
attention and and you know i'm a teacher
by trade really i mean i i have a
a master's in education so like i really
feel like that's just me
like teaching in a different capacity
did you have to teach
john cena how to use the funnel on
blockers
i mean um
i never laughed harder than it was like
three in the morning and i
i was just shouting jokes at john cena
while he was bent over with
hundreds of extras uh yeah that's not uh
john cena is not a man who's afraid to
get naked in front of people like he's
he's totally comfortable
like having his pants down but i was
just yelling jokes at him and i started
laughing so hard because i was like i
went to college and i'm just
yelling at this like at john cena
about how this funnels up his butt you
know like it was just really ridiculous
this tells you about the chrome working
with on this show okay as soon as i
brought up the uh
the cena butt funnel tj looked over at
me goes oh that was my question
that was going to be it jay cannon joins
the show
one of seven you had to get an a college
scholarship
uh in track in order to go to college
correct
yeah i mean there's four of us in
college at the same time so
um you know all four of us had to get
scholarships to be able to afford school
and we all stayed in state so we could
get some you know financial aid so
um and we all did it uh you know my
my i come from a really athletic family
and an academic
family as well so um whether it was an
athletic scholarship or an academic
scholarship like
all of us managed to to make it through
no it's incredible and it's so cool to
hear a filmmaker in your position have
such a great affinity for sports
and and then you know you're able to
switch gears and do something like
cinderella
as well which is coming out on amazon a
totally different
interpretation of cinderella i would
imagine that not so many sports
references pop up in it but tell me
about the experience making the movie
yeah this one i mean this experience
will be unlike any other
i'll ever make uh you know in in the
future because
we were about four weeks into shooting
when we got shut down for the pandemic
and then about five months of the day we
went back and we had
finished and shot the last eight weeks
and
um so all of us really went through
something you know
and um and i really was so grateful to
to have the work and and you know when
when the world was shut down and there
were no live performances i was every
day like i was seeing these amazing live
performances
and these you know um and and actually
um there is a little bit of sport in it
uh there's not sport references in
cinderella but like um
nick gillistein who plays the prince he
uh
was a really great rugby player and
he's so like like again like casting
somebody who i thought was coachable
like he had to learn how to ride a horse
he had
he's not you know like he had really
trained to to dance at a certain level
um and sing in a different way that was
maybe outside
his comfort zone and he just killed it
he did so great
um and so you know like you know the
dancers are athletes so in that way i
was really like it was kind of
it was kind of exciting uh but the movie
is just really
joyful and fun and um
a good time and i'm hoping that people
will just sing
along and dance and laugh and in a time
when we probably
really need to be doing those things we
look forward to the film
and we look forward to seeing justin
fields under center for the chicago
bears i think the longer they have andy
dalton the more problems you guys have
uh i wish you luck this year best of
luck thanks so much kay appreciate it
thank you kate cannon joining the show
pitch perfect writer
right around 30 rock and directed john
cena with a butt funnel
in blockers hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here